that I'm sorry I'm not ariana grande
clearly you know what you love more than
watching endless victorious reruns
watching Victoria Justice ariana grande
elizabeth gillies and Danielle Monet
mess up their lines fall over and suffer
epic prop fails who made the most
mistakes on set ariana grande made her
voice much more high-pitched when she
played Cat Valentine
hey boy over there is eating funky nut
blast so it's easy to tell when she
drops out of character and that's what
happened when she kept saying roll
instead of part oh yeah and then Kate
would get to play you're all oh my god
oh yeah and then Jade will get to play
at all okay it's one thing to get your
line wrong once but to mess up over and
over again that's really frustrating for
everyone none more so than Ariana
herself it's all sorts of fun to sneak
up behind the scenes look at the show
especially when it involves epic fails
like these bloopers it's not just their
memories that let them down these actors
also have their bodies to blame for some
of the funniest bloopers on the show
like the time when Victoria Justice fell
right off her chair it's not often we
get to see Tori Vega making such a
hilarious mistake we're certainly glad
she didn't actually hurt herself
because that means we get the green
light to laugh along with Victoria and
with her cast mates - who knew a chair
could be such a tricky prop to master
sitting on a chair shouldn't be that
hard right but standing on a table in a
pair of skyscraper high heels we can
appreciate why daniella monet toppled a
ride over her character Trina Vega was
so excited to show off her new shoes and
it seems like Daniella got a bit too
carried away in the moment
[Music]
to be fair to the actor she tried really
hard to carry on but once you've fallen
off a table it's pretty hard to come
back from that actors have so many lines
to learn you'd think they wouldn't have
the energy to memorize more than they
needed to but that's exactly what
elizabeth gillies did when she
accidentally said Ariana's line stayed
west talked right over cat as the pair
of actors said the same phrase at the
same time you know you can't sing here
why would we want to Ariana didn't seem
to mind though she just laughed at her
co-stars mistake hey Elizabeth don't
make it harder than it needs to be just
learn your own lines next time we have
to take our hats off to actors for
remembering all those lines and we're
not surprised that they sometimes forget
what they're supposed to say but
forgetting what their own character is
called
that's pretty hilarious and Arianna gave
us that laugh when she included the name
cat in a list of people okay Robby Beck
and cat I'm Kat there's that
unmistakable change in the pitch of her
voice when she realizes she's referred
to herself in the third person it's
thought that this blooper is a reference
to the Spongebob Squarepants episode
called missing identity when Patrick
says hi Patrick no wait
I'm Patrick in showbiz circles they say
never work with animals and Victoria
discovered why when she tried to put a
bunny rabbit down again and again to be
fair to the actress she tried her
absolute best to keep the bunny still
without hurting it but when a rabbit's
made up its mind nothing's going to stop
it hopping away at least Victoria wasn't
hopping mad she saw the funny side of
the frustrating situation and that bunny
is still totally adorable he also say
never work with children but that's
usually because they're the ones messing
up the scene not because they're the
ones pointing out the older actors
mistake however that's just what
happened to Daniella a nine-year-old
extra put her into her place when she
messed up her lines during an airplane
scene
my feet what I can say said of that to
give Daniella credit where it's due she
immediately admitted it was her bad
rather than trying to blame it on anyone
else the Victoria still took great
delight in pointing out that a little
kid called her out we didn't realize the
words help take care of Trina we're
quite so tricky to recite that is until
Elizabeth kept getting her words in a
muddle again and again I gotta take care
of Trina you want to stay here in tough
kitchen kitchen you want to stay here in
hell key terribly sorry
she just invented a whole new tongue
twister for the rest of us to practice
actors have to multitask all the time
they need to remember what actions to
make and what words to say so we
completely understand that sometimes
they can't keep on top of everything
like when Ariana got so carried away
with her actions that she forgot
everything she was meant to say
afterwards
sometimes when you're juggling a lot of
balls some are going to fall down at
least she had a laugh as she realized
her mind had gone blank you know what
doesn't seem so hard to say little girl
the Victoria just couldn't get her head
or should we say mouth around it
oh my god you were the mom one more time
sorry sorry the little girl it's hard to
say she had to do take after take to get
those two simple words right if you've
ever sat up close to a live stage show
you might well have seen spit flying
from the actors mouths as they clearly
pronounce each syllable and Daniella
experienced that issue when she
accidentally drooled down her own face
the thing is we wouldn't have been any
the wiser if she hadn't pointed it out
she could have carried on regardless but
it was just draw you know so far we've
learned you should never work with
animals or kids but scissors your mom
probably told you not to play with
scissors right we guess Elizabeth which
is she listened to that advice when her
seen with a pair of scissors went awry
it just goes to show that sometimes the
props will mess you up
she was lucky that it was just an
instrument case that the scissors got
jammed into it could have been so much
worse we've already seen or should we
say heard how Ariana's voice can change
a lot oh and then Jade will get to play
here all sure she knows she's got
amazing vocal range as a singer but she
also has a wide range in her speaking
voice too and in this scene she takes
her voice to an even lower pitch when
messing around she keeps in character
though by calling Victoria Tori you love
seeing the cast playing around like this
and letting loose do a bit we're not
sure that the director would agree with
us though ever wonder why the cast
sometimes can't say their lines right
Victoria explained it all when she said
her tongue was numb and she couldn't say
this is she even tried to warm up her
tongue by making a load of bunny sounds
with it yeah
yeah we can appreciate that after
talking all day on set your mouth is
going to get pretty tired we're
surprised it doesn't happen more often
to be honest maybe they should teach
tongue warm-up exercises in acting
classes like singers do vocal warm-ups
at least Victoria managed to say words
even if they didn't make much sense
sometimes actors don't just say the
wrong word they say words that don't
even exist
Elizabeth shows that when in doubt just
talk nonsense in a silly voice it's like
she's on the Muppet Show rather than
victorious at least being silly gets
everyone else laughing rather than
complaining that you forgot your line
again one measure of a true professional
is their ability to keep on going when
they've messed up no seriously all
singer/dancer I could just stand on the
front at least she managed to stand up
on a piece of furniture this time it was
just the words that escaped her flow
like right in front and just sorry I
tried to keep going we wonder how many
times the actors on Victorious
successfully managed to cover up their
mistakes and how many times unscripted
lines made it into the show I met the
rap of the moon bags that it purchases
vehicle of course most of the time
things go wrong by accident not on
purpose like the time when Victoria was
sitting at the table with Leon Thomas it
wasn't her fault that she got taken by
surprise by a ball flying across the
table it surprised Leon aka Andre Harris
- that's yet another pop to add to the
list of things to avoid on set a lot of
actors on Nickelodeon shows have also
trained as singers and dancers so it
makes sense that they might slip into a
little song and dance number naturally
like when Daniela broke into a silly
song and dance when she messed up her
lines so listen I'm totally gonna win
it's totally adorable and a pretty
clever way of defusing any stress about
the situation we're finishing up with
another blooper that isn't totally
accidental well at least that's the case
for one of the actors when Elisabeth
deliberately jumped out to surprise her
co-stars she knew what she was doing it
certainly lightened the atmosphere and
Elisabeth looked pretty pleased with
herself even giving herself a clap if
you love all these Peaks behind the
scenes then you'll want to check out the
season 2 finale of the series the
episode is called blue toria's and is
packed full of the cast's major mess ups
so that's a wrap on the best bloopers in
Victorious which blooper made you laugh
the most be sure to let us know in the
comments please give this video a big
thumbs up and subscribe to our Channel
we'll see you next time thanks for
watching